hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Norwegian Supernatural
Thriller film called the Innocence
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie opens up with a family
traveling to their new home in the
suburbs inside the car a little girl Eda
seems annoyed by her autistic sister
Anna who is always humming out of anger
she pinches her heart but Anna feels no
pain in the next scene the family
arrives at their new home and the
children begin exploring the empty rooms
soon Eda goes to a nearby lake where she
notices an earthworm crawling she steps
on the earth room multiple times until
it dies just then Eden notices a boy
looking at her from the other side of
the lake the next day she visits the
playground and finds a number of
grown-ups playing football she goes near
them and keeps on looking at their game
but none of them give her any attention
later Ben the boy whom she saw across
the lake arrives there and befriends her
after that he takes Eda into the woods
and shows her his superpower he asks Eda
to drop a bottle cap and changes its
direction as it falls Ida tries to do
the same but fails shortly after she
returns home and tells her parents about
Ben's Powers but none of them seem to
believe her seeing her parents giving
more attention to Anna Eda feels jealous
hence she puts a broken piece of glass
inside her shoes after some time the mom
Henriette takes Anna for a walk and the
little girl puts on the same shoes
surprisingly she doesn't even Flinch
indicating that she doesn't feel any
pain the scene then shifts to Aisha
another girl living in a nearby building
she is playing with her doll while her
cat sits aside later when she puts on
her shoes to go outside she gets injured
as if there is something sharp in her
shoes but when she looks at her wound
the blood vanishes meanwhile Anna's
parents are talking with a therapist
about her condition right then she gets
up from her seat and starts thumping her
feet after returning home from the
therapist Henriette takes off Anna's
shoes and notices blood all over her
socks on the other hand Aisha is
searching for her cat outside the
building when she enters another
building and climbs upstairs she notices
a doorknob moving and it's Anna on the
other side Aisha also goes ahead and
holds the doorknob after a pause both of
them leave the doorknob at the same time
later at night after her mother puts her
to bed Aisha hears strange voices from
around the apartment the next day Eda
takes Anna for a walk in the playground
Ben also arrives there and the two head
off leaving Anna alone in the swing they
try to play football but the senior boys
bully bed and send him away after a
while he brings out a cat which is
revealed to be Aisha's he drops it from
a height to see if it can successfully
land on its feet and just like that I
hate this kid more than any other kid
I've ever known when the duo rushes
downstairs to inspect they find the cat
lying on the floor injured Ben
immediately finishes it off to put it
out of its misery yep I hate this child
Ida clearly bothered by this simply
walks away on reaching the park she
finds Anna playing with Aisha it appears
as if the two have formed a connection
between them the next day Ida leaves her
sister to play with Aisha and walks
towards the basement to inspect the dead
cat however she is shocked to find the
cat missing she then returns to her
sister and sees her with Ben they are
playing with a frisbee which keeps
spinning for an unusually long time Eda
believes it's Ben's doing but the latter
denies it he reveals that it's actually
being done by her sister Anna following
this Ida asks Ben to show his
concentration power off by directing
away a falling Stone he does so and asks
Aisha to do the same but she refuses
this makes Eda realize that Aisha's
special power is to have telepathic
connections with other people after that
they decide to check if Ben has Aisha's
powers of hearing Ben can easily hear
the words when Eda Whispers to Aisha but
has difficulty understanding when Eda
Whispers to Anna at the same time Eda
gets a call from her mom asking them to
return home for dinner once they return
Ida Whispers the word shark into her
sister's ears hoping that the others
will hear it surprisingly Aisha who is
at her home draws a shark on her window
while Anna draws one on her magnetic
board even Ben draws the shark with mud
and sand on his table the next day Ida
and Anna are near the woods trying to
test Ben's ability to hear long
distances once they reach far Ida
Whispers something in Anna's ears making
fun of Ben surprisingly he hears it and
in a fit of rage he pushes Aisha
telepathically he also throws a stone at
Eda it's on a crash course with her face
but she is able to dodge it in time when
Ben marches towards Aisha to punish her
Anna blocks his way with this the two
special kids get into a telepathic fight
causing the dirt and branches near them
to move they even end up breaking a
large log behind them because of the
impact a splinter is lodged deep inside
Anna's leg Eda tells everyone not to
worry as she believes her sister doesn't
feel pain however Aisha contradicts that
she can she just cannot express it after
reaching home Henriette notices Anna's
wound and inquires with Eda about where
they had been the whole day Ida tries
lying about it but Henriette scolds her
for being irresponsible and Reckless if
only she knew they were playing Dragon
Ball Z in the woods the scene then
shifts to Ben's apartment where he's
playing with his food he concentrates on
a hot boiling pot and makes it move
spilling some water Ben laughs when he
is able to do so his mother tries to
grab the pot but gets her hand burnt in
the process seeing Ben laughing she
thinks that he's making fun of her and
scolds him at the same time Ben drops a
pan from the Shelf which hits his mother
on the head surprisingly Aisha's mother
also starts bleeding from her head but
when Aisha tells her about it she is not
able to see the blood elsewhere Ben just
stares at his mother while she lies on
the floor bleeding the evil Maniac then
drops the boiling water on her legs
causing her to scream despite this Ben
feels No Remorse if Ben were a real
child I would slap him I don't even care
I would slap him the next day Henriette
takes Santa outside and sits on a table
reading a book when she notices Anna
playing with Aisha she approaches and is
shocked to hear her daughter speaking
after some days Ben finally comes out of
his house to play but turns around when
he notices the bullies coming towards
him later at night when Ben searches for
food inside the fridge we can see his
mother still lying on the floor he then
goes inside his room and starts banging
a glowing ball to his bed meanwhile a
middle-aged man from another apartment
is shown who seems to be controlled by
someone as he walks out of the door and
stops at the Footbridge he is also
banging a rock in his hand like Ben was
banging the ball before the boy who
bullied Ben in the playground is about
to cross the bridge and as soon as he
walks past the man he silently follows
and attacks him with the rock Ben banged
that ball to beat the bullies on the
bridge the following day Ida wakes up to
her parents talking about an incident on
the Footbridge later Ida and Aisha are
warned by their mothers to not go too
far but they do not listen Eda walks up
to the bridge and notices blood around
the corner she then goes to play with
Ben who reveals that he controls other
people and makes them do the thing that
he wants he calls it fetching which is
scary at first Eda does not believe him
but when Ben controls her and makes her
climb the fridge she becomes scared
later as the two are watching the
bullies play football Ben concentrates
his powers on one of them and breaks his
leg this scares Eda and before she
notices Ben is gone he reaches the woods
where he attacks the approaching Aisha
with a stone the little girl tries to
get up but she starts gasping for breath
and falls to the ground Ben is still not
done he tries to finish Aisha once and
for all but Ida arrives there and pushes
him breaking his concentration angry Ben
tries to attack her but when he sees
Anna approaching from afar he runs away
Anna is the straight-up Gandalf of this
world and Ben better run shortly after
Aisha tries to talk with Anna
telepathically warning her to be careful
with Ben at night when Aisha tries to
sleep she hears Ben thumping his head on
the glass window terrified she calls out
for her mother but the latter is busy
crying in the kitchen late at night Ben
tries to concentrate his powers until he
takes over Aisha's mother suddenly Anna
wakes up from her sleep and seems
worried after Ben succeeds in
controlling Aisha's mother's mind she
finds herself in a dark room sensing
something moving across her balcony she
grabs a knife for safety and starts
walking towards the balcony she turns
around to see a strange looking child
holding a dead rabbit in her hand in
reality it is Aisha holding her toy
bunny but in her mother's mind it is
absolute nightmare fuel afraid the
mother approaches her slowly and stabs
her as soon as Aisha is stabbed Anna
falls on the stairs feeling her friend's
pain right then Ben loses his
concentration and Aisha's mother snaps
out of his control seeing her daughter
dying she cries and holds her in her
arms and his parents also find Anna in
the stairwell and bring her back inside
following Aisha's death Anna loses her
ability to speak and this worries her
parents Ida who knows that it is Ben's
doing decides she must do something
about it later she asks her mom about
what they should do if anyone does
something Henriette suggests that they
should either tell an adult or inform
the police but sometimes you have to
take care of it yourself she also
inquires if anyone is being mean to her
but either replies that everything is
fine the next day Eda decides to deal
with Ben all by herself she steals some
money from her father's wallet and heads
out she then approaches Ben's apartment
holding a toy plane Ida asks Ben to join
her and the two reach the same
Footbridge when Ben goes to throw the
plane standing on the edge of the bridge
Ida prepares to push the little bastard
but then a woman spots them and asks
them to step away from there no no
however refusing to waste the
opportunity Eda pushes Ben down from the
bridge yes and runs away into the woods
hearing the woman still calling out for
her she grabs a piece of glass to
protect herself she also tries to grab a
stick but it turns out to be a big snake
signaling that she's under Ben's control
now terrified she starts screaming and
the very next second she finds herself
in a dark forest with a strange
one-legged approaching her this almost
gives the little girl a heart attack and
when she runs she again reaches the
highway Eda then holds the piece of
glass so tightly that the pain snaps her
out of the illusion she is now in the
middle of the highway with the car
approaching her at high speed Eda jumps
out of the way but the car still hits
her leg in the next scene she finds
herself in the hospital with her mother
by her side Ida quickly asks about Ben
and Henriette reveals that he survived
the fall this upsets the little girl
deeply later Eda arrives home and she
anxiously keeps looking through the
window in one instance she finds Ben
staring at the house this makes her
realize that the evil boy is trying to
control her mother and kill everyone
hence she hides inside the bathroom
shortly after Henriette calls Eda and
informs her to take care of her sister
while she is out Eda slowly comes out of
the bathroom and looks for Anna but
cannot find her around it is then shown
that Anna has already left the house she
is now concentrating her powers to fight
Ben facing him from across the same Lake
that Eda did at the beginning meanwhile
Eda who is in a cast finds it difficult
to use the elevator so she decides to
walk downstairs unfortunately her
support sticks slip and she is unable to
climb down this frustrates Eda so deeply
that she lets out a wild scream a scream
loud enough to break her leg cast after
becoming free of her shackles Eda rushes
to find her sister elsewhere the two
psychic kids come face to face on either
side of the lake then goes first and
unleashes a powerful strike which knocks
Anna down he then walks away thinking
that he has successfully defeated her
however Anna stands back up and starts
concentrating her powers once again this
time all the babies around them start
crying while the young kids feel
something strange around them after a
while Eda also joins her sister and all
the children in the area come out to
their balconies to stare at Ben their
combined positive power is finally able
to defeat the little
is finally able to defeat the evil power
of Ben causing him to die on the spot
after this everyone returns to their
home as if nothing happened in the last
scene Henriette arrives back home and
asks Eda about what happened to the cast
on her leg she does not say anything and
simply hugs her mother tight Anna on the
other hand can be seen scribbling and
erasing something on her tablet
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching